nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
direction le Brésil qui s'apprête à
élire son président et parmi les
candidats un revenant Lula il est le
candidat du renouveau du Brésil pour les
uns un démon du passé symbole de la
corruption pour les autres premier
président de gauche du pays il a mis en
place pendant ces deux mandats une
réforme sociale des bourses étudiantes
un accès aux soins gratuits des
logements à loyer modérés Lula a changé
la vie de millions de personnes au
Brésil Fanny leter bonjour vous vous
êtes correspondante de France 24 on vous
retrouve à Rio de Janeiro pour réaliser
le reportage qu'on va découvrir dans un
instant vous avez arpenté le Brésil
pendant des semaines Lula c'est un
destin incroyable c'est aussi le destin
d'une nation
oui lui-même qui est issu d'un milieu
très pauvre Lula se dit l'incarnation de
ce Brésil populaire qu'il aime rappeler
qu'il a sorti de la misère et de la fin
lorsqu'il a accédé à la présidence en
2003 mais c'est aussi un personnage vous
l'avez dit très contesté accusé de
corruption qui a passé plus de 2 ans en
prison et qui aujourd'hui tel un phénix
renaît de ses cendres et concours de
nouveau à l'élection présidentielle pour
la sixième fois alors on a voulu
comprendre cet héritage là on a voulu
questionner les Brésiliens qui ont
grandi sous ces deux mandats ou ceux qui
ont voté pour lui et qui sont
aujourd'hui très déçus Brésil l'héritage
Lula reportage signé Louise Rollet et
Fanny Leterre qu'on retrouve dans un
instant
[Musique]
au cœur du quartier chic de gavéa
ces jours de campagne à l'Université
pontificale
[Applaudissements]
président dilmar oucef est la députée
benedita Da Silva fervente supportrice
du candidat Loula sont venus parler
discrimination raciale et égalité des
chances
il y a une inégalité sociale si grande
dans ce pays si riche
mais nous subissons aussi une inégalité
qui n'est pas seulement sociale mais qui
n'en demeure pas moins une priorité
nationale c'est celle de l'inégalité
raciale
dans la foule conquise nombreux sont
ceux qui ont bénéficié des quotas ratio
et des bourses mises en place par le
gouvernement de l'Oly
il faut voter le numéro 13
c'est Loula avec toute notre force avec
toute votre jeunesse
toute une génération qui est entrée à
l'université grâce à l'ancien président
comme Magda Gomez 28 ans
la jeune militante du Parti des
travailleurs a été la première de sa
famille avoir pu accéder à
l'enseignement supérieur
[Musique]
depuis dans son sillage
des milliers d'autres étudiants mais
leur héritage est menacé
[Applaudissements]
je suis venu ici il y a 8 ans maintenant
8 ou 9 ans j'ai suivi le cours
d'ingénieur et j'étais la seule femme
noire oui la seule femme noire a
participé au cours il faut rompre tout
de suite avec la politique de bolsonaro
élire Lula au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle parce que Lula a un
projet pour le Brésil et le futur du
pays sans lui on ne va faire que revenir
en arrière
un espoir pour Magda des milliers de
jeunes
[Musique]
pourtant considéré comme une menace pour
d'autres
[Musique]
à plus de 2000 km de la bienvenue à
Santa Cruz ou CAPI Bari B
en plein cœur du père Hambourg terre
natal de Lula et fief historique du
Parti des travailleurs
la ville devenue prospère grâce à la
confection de vêtements et la seule de
l'État à avoir retourné sa veste
j'ai ma plaque d'immatriculation je suis
bolsonaro 2022
Dieu patrie et familles
le Brésil au-dessus de tout et Dieu
au-dessus de tous
nous sommes dans un univers parallèle
ici à Santa Cruz la terre de la
confection textile dans le nord-est du
Brésil
comme la majorité de la ville
David José Pereira a voté pour gear
bolsonaro en 2018
c'est pour faire des t-shirts pour les
patriotes
l'entrepreneur de 54 ans on a même fait
son métier
il confectionne des t-shirts aux
couleurs du Brésil et à la gloire du
président qui se vendent comme des
petits pains
on doit couper en quatre tailles SM L et
XL
à l'image de son nord-est brésilien
historiquement à gauche David a voté
Lula en 2002 mais selon lui les
politiques sociales mise en place
pendant sa présidence ont appauvri la
région
il n'a pas mis en place de politique qui
ont assisté au développement
entrepreneurial il n'a fait que
subventionner les aides sociales créer
des assistés
ce n'est pas le profil des petits
entrepreneurs indépendants comme nous
parce qu'au final qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé dans la tête de l'habitant du
nord-est qui n'a jamais été à l'école et
qui n'est pas informé
je vais m'inscrire pour recevoir la
location familiale de 1880 et il ne
cherchez pas de travail parce que sinon
elle ne recevait plus la location une
allocation de misère qui ne suffisait ni
pour s'alimenter ni pour économiser pour
son avenir
un sentiment d'amertume qui a contaminé
jusqu'au propres alliés de Lullin
San Paolo la capitale économique du
Brésil
au cœur de cette forêt urbaine
les peuples indigènes se sont donnés
rendez-vous pour défendre leurs droits
et leur territoire
[Musique]
en première ligne les candidates députés
Sonia guajajara et Shirley pankara
[Musique]
luttons contre les élus des mairies des
États qui cautionnent cette politique
génocidaire de ce gouvernement
si tous ici s'estime menacé par Jaïr
bolsonaro
pour Shirley pas question pour autant de
données un chèque en blanc à son
principal dans la course à la présidence
combien de retour en arrière avons-nous
vécu dans ce pays combien de nous sommes
victimes des politiques mortelles
instaurées dans ce pays
la candidate était à ses côtés lorsqu'il
y a quelques mois lola a signé une
lettre garantissant la protection et la
démarcation de leur terre une promesse
électorale dont Shirley se méfie
c'est important de rappeler que même si
certains nous défendent et veulent
dialoguer avec les peuples indigènes ce
n'est pas suffisant elles doivent nous
donner le droit de nous exprimer
car elle se souvient en matière de
droits indigènes Lula traîne de
nombreuses casseroles comme la
construction du barrage belomonté qui a
détruit une importante partie du bassin
du Shinku en Amazonie
je peux vous dire que je suis de gauche
mais je peux aussi vous dire qu'on doit
beaucoup s'améliorer je ne peux pas
oublier la construction du barrage de
Belo Monte ni avec le peu de terre
indigènes qui ont été délimités
je ne peux pas dire que tout est rose à
gauche
[Musique]
à Rio nous retrouvons Magda la jeune
assistante parlementaire et militante du
Parti des travailleurs
chaque soir elle traverse la ville pour
rentrer chez elle
à rossignat la plus grande favela du
pays
un meilleur futur pour moi cela voulait
dire avoir d'autres conditions de vie
que ma famille mais sans perdre mes
racines c'est ça ne sert à rien que
j'arrive à sortir de la favela et que je
découvre le monde si je ne suis pas
capable de revenir dans ma vie dans ma
rossinia
fier de ses racines avec sa mère
sa tante et sa grand-mère
elle a grandi dans ce dédale de Ruelle
originaire de l'État de Bahia elles sont
arrivées ici dans les années 80 avec
pour seule perspective devenir des
domestiques
elle vivait dans un bidonville sur les
hauteurs de la favela sans eau sans
électricité et bien peu de nourriture
lola a tout changé pour elle jusque dans
leur assiette
pour la première fois un gouvernement
nous a donné la possibilité parce que
c'est un droit d'acheter de la viande
c'est la meilleure chose qui est pu nous
arriver on a eu enfin accès à des
denrées réservés aux riches et
aujourd'hui la viande disparaît de
nouveau de la table des Brésiliens avec
le gouvernement bolsonaro on a plus la
possibilité d'acheter de la viande c'est
devenu trop cher
j'ai tellement peu mangé de viande dans
ma vie que je sais même pas la cuisine
aujourd'hui si Magda a les moyens
d'inviter à dîner sa famille et ses amis
c'est selon elle grâce à l'ancien
président
en plus d'avoir eu accès à des bourses
pour étudier
la famille de Magda bénéficie de la mise
en place de programmes révolutionnaires
à l'époque des allocations familiales et
un accès à la propriété
j'étais déjà fan du Parti des
Travailleurs regardez je m'habille en
rouge des petites tatie je me souviens
de la maison dans l'intérieur des terres
qu'on a gagné grâce au programme d'accès
à la propriété ma vie ma maison il y a
eu aussi le programme électricité pour
tous il y a eu tellement de politiques
sociales grâce au gouvernement qui avait
compris à l'époque que le développement
social l'éducation et la répartition des
richesses étaient essentielles quand
vous donnez accès à la propriété aux
aides au logement au tout-à-l'égout et à
l'éducation gratuite ou donner au final
bien plus que ça aux gens ce n'est pas
une allocation familiale qui a changé la
vie des Brésiliens surtout que ce
n'était pas grand chose à l'époque
peut-être 6 euros un
héritage Lula
[Musique]
qui a transformé la vie de millions de
Brésiliens comme Magda
[Musique]
mais qu'à l'autre bout du pays
à Santa Cruz do CAPI Bari B
on souhaite oublier à tout prix
la ville du nord-est se prépare à
recevoir ce jour-là son candidat jaillir
bolsonaro
si le président vient ici aujourd'hui
c'est parce qu'il a été invité par David
et ses amis motards
pour eux bolsonaro est le seul capable
de sauver leur pays détruit par la
gauche au pouvoir pendant près de 16 ans
les scandales de corruption du Parti des
Travailleurs puis l'emprisonnement de 4
ans et demi les ont traumatisés
pour personne
on ne supportera pas d'avoir un
président communiste un président qui
veut transformer notre pays et teindre
notre drapeau en rouge
contre ce qu'il désigne comme leur
ennemi communiste
David et ses acolytes trouve leur salut
dans le drapeau brésilien
[Musique]
ah regarde je lui ai donné le t-shirt et
il l'a pris j'ai le cœur qui bat à 1000
à l'heure bourré d'adrénaline c'est que
du bonheur c'est l'incarnation de la
décence de la morale et de l'éthique au
gouvernement
[Musique]
selon un dernier sondage pourtant le
nord-est du Brésil roulent encore pour
la gauche
au premier tour ici Lola remporterait
largement face à herbolsonaro
[Musique]
difficile d'effacer complètement
l'héritage Lula
en banlieue de Rio
il est attendu comme un sauveur ce soir
là
dans cette ville populaire dominée par
le trafic et la milice Lula s'est trouvé
les mots toujours les mêmes lui qui a
fait naître à l'époque une classe
moyenne brésilienne
on ne veut plus être pauvre on veut
vivre bien manger bien possédez une
bonne voiture on veut pouvoir voyager
Magda ne raterai pour rien au monde un
de ces meetings
pour l'occasion elle a donné rendez-vous
à ses amis toutes militante comme elle
novaiguassu est un fief électoral de
Jaïr bolsonaro mais c'est aussi un
bastion de travailleurs
c'est la dernière ligne droite
nous sommes de la génération qui est né
avec des droits qui aujourd'hui nous
sont retirés on a de nouveau espoirs que
tout revienne que notre démocratie
fonctionne de nouveau comme elle se doit
nous sommes et nous serons la révolution
cette révolution doit avoir lieu pour
qu'on puisse continuer à appliquer les
politiques mises en place à l'époque et
qui sont importantes pour nous
et les espèrent que leurs candidats
remportera l'élection des mêmes le
premier tour
favoris des sondages Lula entend bien
revenir en force et faire raviver la
flamme du passé pour les quatre années à
venir
[Musique]
on se retrouve en plateau avec Fanny
Lotter à Rio de Janeiro après ce grand
tour du Brésil Fanny c'est une lutte des
classes une lutte raciale aussi qui se
joue
oui ça paraît assez étonnant de se
rendre compte que celui qui incarne la
lutte pour l'égalité raciale est en fait
un homme blanc mais ce qu'il faut
comprendre et ce qu'on a réalisé en
rencontrant les sympathisants de
l'olylin c'est que il n'a pas de couleur
il représente des idées des politiques
qui l'a mis en place tout au long de ces
mandats qui ont été repris par sa
successeur d'ilmar Rousset comme on s'en
est rendu compte lorsqu'on a interrogé
ce jeune qu'on a rencontré lors de notre
reportage
on va pouvoir reconstruire la démocratie
brésilienne et qu'on va instaurer plus
de participation sociale
sous les gouvernements de Lula on a vu
que le peuple a eu pour la première fois
la possibilité de participer activement
aux décisions qui le concernaient grâce
à toutes les politiques mises en place
quand Lula était au pouvoir
son prochain mandat est décisif parce
qu'on doit de nouveau participer on doit
reprendre le pouvoir
surtout les personnes noires on exige
une réparation on veut que soit mise en
place des politiques pour obtenir une
réparation pour les années de
discrimination les 500 ans d'esclavage
on veut pouvoir avoir davantage accès à
l'université aux écoles on veut une
santé gratuite et bonne pour tous
leur famille Lula ne laisse personne
indifférent il y a une vraie
polarisation au Brésil
oui Lula cristallise l'amour comme la
haine et on s'en
rend compte pour ses sympathisants pas
question que nous la revienne au pouvoir
s'il accepte de nouveau la présidence
c'est simple pour eux c'est qu'il y a eu
fraude électorale et cristallise la
haine des sympathisants de jerbolsenaro
pour qui il incarne le diable le mal le
retour du communisme qui menace en
Amérique latine et on le sent dans cette
campagne une vraie radicalisation on a
vu de nombreuses agressions éclatées
dans tout le pays certains militants ont
même été tués et cela inquiète et
interroge jusqu'où ces violences pour
étaler en cas de victoire de Lula merci
beaucoup Fanny on va suivre avec vous
évidemment cette la fin de cette
campagne et cette élection
présidentielle au Brésil avec nos
correspondants mais aussi nos envoyés
spéciaux qui sont en train de prendre le
chemin du Brésil c'est la fin de ce
magazine merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de reporter sur Facebook
[Musique]